so I'm a big calendar person I really
like having a deadline when I was
started writing this book my due dates
in like 4 weeks or something like that
and it's not like I look at it
frequently but it's just out there yeah
it's just this thing that gets put into
your psyche and somehow you can work
backwards so much easier from a date so
it sounds so silly but most humans will
say well in 1 year or 3 years or 5 years
I'm like put it on your calendar like
whatever that actual timeline is and
then try to work backwards and then for
most goals I believe in short-term goals
100% maybe daily weekly monthly annually
but three or 5e goals who knows so like
I might have a really big vision for 10
years or 20 years but as I get closer I
might realize oh God actually nope
that's not what I want so allowing
yourself that freedom to not want to be
the hot sexy Rich millionaire with
Bentley's and instead say oh no what I
actually want to do is I want to talk
about what I want to talk about with
whom I want to talk about owning
companies I want to and having no master
that's what Rich looks like for me and
if you had stuck with your original
goals that wouldn't have been the case
hey it's EV Carmichael and I make these
videos because I need them because I
want to wake up every single day and get
pushed by somebody who's doing a lot
more than me and in watching their
videos it inspires me to be bolder to
have more courage and go chase down the
life of my dreams and I hope it does the
same for you so today let's learn the 10
steps to achieve any goal
enjoy set number two is visualize
failure with Andrew huberman what does
the science say about visualizing big
goals if you're somebody who's
interested in business or let's say
you're focused on relationship is
thinking about the perfect relationship
and what that would look like and the
the family that you would have and where
you would live is that effective in
generating the kinds of behaviors that
will lead you to that is it effective to
think about the big win at the end well
it turns out it is but you have to be
very very careful with when and how you
implement that visualization because if
you do it correctly it can really serve
your goal-seeking well and if you do it
incorrectly it can undermine the entire
process so does visualization Work Well
turns out that visualization of the big
win the end goal so the Super Bowl win
or eight gold medals in the Olympics or
graduation from the University of your
choice or making a certain amount of
money or finding the partner of your
choice Etc that visualization is
effective in getting the goal Pursuit
process started
but it actually is a pretty lousy and
maybe even counterproductive way of
maintaining pursuit of that goal meaning
continuing to engage the sort of actions
that are going to get you to eventually
achieve that goal I think this is going
to be surprising to people at first but
if we think back to our discussion about
the physiology of the blood pressure
system it'll make
sense good scientific Studies have been
done where people are told to imagine or
even script out their long-term vision
and goal for themselves what is the big
goal and they're taught to or told to
imagine it with a rich amount of detail
to think about how it's going to feel in
their body and the big win and basically
what happens is if you measure people's
blood pressure or other metrics of
physiology you see an increase in that
systolic blood pressure there's an kind
of a ramping up of the Readiness and
excitement for that goal but that
increase in blood pressure quickly wains
and over time that visual of the
long-term goal becomes a poor thing to
rely on in order to generate the actions
that are required to reach that goal in
fact there's a much better way to
maintain ongoing action toward a goal
that also involves visualization but it
turns out it's not about visualizing
success it's about visualizing failure
the balus lab and other labs have looked
at whether or not people make progress
toward goals of different types whether
or not they're thinking about the goal
they're thinking about that goal line
and what they want to achieve that
long-term goal and all the wonderful
things associated with it or whether or
not they are thinking about all the ways
in which they could fail and root to
that goal right this is not typically
what we are encouraged to do typically
we are told don't imagine failure push
failure out of your mind only focus on
success you know fake it till you make
it or it's a phrase that I absolutely
hate a Frank because it's not even clear
what that means and it's not even clear
what the ethical form of that is I think
it means continue despite any anxiety or
fear that things won't work out but if
you look at the literature the
scientific literature what the balus lab
and other labs have shown is that
there's a near doubling near doubling
the probability of reaching one's goal
if you focus R routinely on
foreshadowing failure you think about
the ways in which things could fail if
you take action a or you take action B
and instead therefore you take action C
you're supposed to think about how
things could fail if you don't get up
and run each morning if your goal is say
a fitness goal so let's use that as an
example because even though I realize
people are in pursuit of many things not
just Fitness fitness goals and physical
goals are a very concrete thing that we
can all get on the same page about
because they're related to actions let's
say somebody is sets a goal of running
five miles four times a week minimum and
as many as seven four times a week
minimum before 8: a.m. okay in a
previous podcast on habits I talked
about the benefits of not necessarily
setting specific times that one will do
things but setting time blocks that one
will do things so you say before 8: a.m.
you're going to run five miles and
that's going to happen up to seven days
a week okay one version of this would be
okay sit back in a chair and think about
how great you're going to feel and look
if you're doing this every day how your
health is going to improve how
everything's going to your blood markers
of lipids Etc are going to improve okay
fine that's the visualization goal of
visualizing the end point turns out that
is far less effective and maybe even
counterproductive compared to thinking
about what's going to happen if you
don't do this the negative Health
outcomes that are going to occur the
disappointment you're going to have in
yourself the fact that you're going to
wait until 7:30 that's not long enough
for many people to run five miles you go
to put it on your shoes it's going to be
pouring rain or even hailing or snowing
outside and now you're not going outside
unless you're somebody who's
particularly motivated to do that
okay so foreshadowing failure turns out
to be the best way to motivate toward
goal pursuit in fact as I mentioned
before there's a near doubling in the
likelihood that people will reach goals
of any kind when they're constantly
thinking about how bad it's going to be
if they fail if we think back to the
neural circuit associated with assessing
value in our goal Pursuits this makes
perfect sense the amydala that center of
the brain that's involved in anxiety and
fear and worry well the amydala is one
of the four core components of our goal
setting and goal Pursuit circuitry and
there's no bypassing that there is no
one listening to this or watching this
who's a migdala is not involved in their
goal setting and goal Pursuit behavior
and so while I'd love to be able to tell
you that all you should think about is
rainbows and puppies and all the
wonderful rewarding things that are
going to happen when you achieve your
goals the truth is you should be
thinking mainly about how bad it's
really going to get if you don't do it
how disappointing in yourself you're
going to feel how it will negatively
impact you if not in the immediate term
in the long term if indeed your goal is
to reach your goal so I want to
emphasize that I'm not interested in
encouraging people to flagellate
themselves I'm encouraging people
to achieve their goals and it turns out
the best way to do that is by
foreshadowing failure and the more
specific you can get by writing down or
thinking about or talking about how bad
it will be if you don't achieve your
goals the more likely you are to achieve
those goals step number three is look at
your goals daily with Brendan brashard
did you look at your goals every day
this year every day did you look at your
goals every day this year it's such a
simple question every day I don't mean
once in a while every day and if you
didn't my invitation to you is to
consider the fact that maybe the amount
of time that you're spending with your
goals is not sufficient enough to
motivate you maybe the amount of time
you're spending with your goals is not
sufficient enough to keep you focused
maybe the amount of time you're spending
with your goals is not sufficient enough
to activate that unconscious brain that
says huh I know how to achieve that
maybe it's the reason you're not coming
up with more ideas in the shower in the
morning because you're not queuing your
brain with enough representation or
enough um sorry repetition of looking at
your specific goals because when you
look at your specific goals over and
over and over and over again day after
day after day after day it literally
helps rewire your brain and it helps
program your brain to say oh let me pay
attention to ideas thoughts and feelings
I have consciously and unconsciously
that might be able to manifest these
goals this is why having a visual
representation of what you are after and
looking at it every day is so critical
to all of personal development training
of all time but why is it that so many
people still don't do it they just get
caught up more people look at other
people's Instagram every day than they
do their own goals and we wonder why so
many people are struggling to achieve
things faster step number four is write
your goals down with Grant Cardone when
I woke up what I did was I grabbed a
legal pad next to
me and uh I just simply start writing in
present
tense or in past tense but not in
future things that I'd like to
accomplish in my lifetime these are
really short notes like hey let's say
let's say the yacht's on my mind I'd
like to own a yacht one day right or
maybe you don't want to own one you want
a chared One whatever I would just write
down a uh 300t
yacht I don't really have to get
specific at that time about whether I'm
going to own it or Charter it doesn't
really matter to me you could be
specific but I'm just trying to bring my
mind to some attention this is an Ever
almost everent process except for except
for finding the
notepad and writing this is this does
not require thinking or how to or
mechanics okay so like I might write
okay I want 100,000 units we're 10,000
12,000 units right now in our real
estate portfolio and I'm like I want to
get to 100,000 units so I'm just going
to write 100,000 plus
units uh what else did I write this
morning see every day I'm doing I'm
doing it really I'm doing it three times
a day I'm doing it morning and I'm doing
it at night and the third time I'll do
it is any anytime I have a fail an upset
um a setback some rejection I didn't get
what I wanted then I I will write down
and go right hey man yacht I want a home
in Italy I remember I used to write uh
that I wanted a house if you go back and
read the 10x rule you'll hear one of my
notes in there was to own a home in
Florence Italy showed up for a while
okay motorcycle showed up for a while
helicopter showed up for a while but
some of this just comes and goes in the
morning when I'm writing down my goals
it's almost a form of active
meditation okay where I'm just like
literally scanning my mind for ideas of
things I'd like to accomplish in my
lifetime whatever pops up I write it
down this whole exercise maybe last 3
minutes 4 minutes long uh I leave the
writings scribblings if you will uh in
the notepad more often than not when and
when the notepad is full I just simply
throw it in the trash so it's not like
I'm doing anything
it requires any effort here okay it's
quick it's fast it's
easy uh I want a great marriage okay so
boom I'm I'm on great health I don't
know what that looks like exactly what
is great health to look like to
everybody I don't know it should grow
older it means different things and then
it opens me up oh I want my 10x Health
System I want a have a million clients
on 10xl
system uh on U Cardone Capital 100 ,000
100,000 units and I want one uh what do
I have 14,000 investors right now want
140,000 investors Cardone Equity Group
okay I want to raise a billion dollars
for Cardone Equity Group and
democratize alternative Investments for
everyday people so they're not just
freaking taken advantage of by or
monopolized by Goldman and JP and uh the
cares and the KKR to were all these big
giant
funds see what's happening I'm doing it
right now right I'm just not writing it
down now the significance of writing it
down is it kind of just gets the juices
flowing and I personally find it to be
better when I'm doing
it with ink than if I'm doing it on a
notepad on my phone also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there Step number five is set realistic
goals with John ass ra as you well well
well are aware there's the setting goal
part and we use our imagination and our
deductive reasoning I want this or that
not this not that pretty easy right but
what do you do when you're uncertain
when you have either some self-doubt or
you're lacking the knowledge or the
skills to achieve the goals that you
want what do you do when that brings up
some fear and some uncertainty that
causes you to maybe procrastinate or not
take
action so there's a couple things that
you can do one is set a goal that you
know how to achieve and so I'll give you
just a little example uh I haven't been
able to run in years do some injuries
and so I recently set a weight goal that
uh I knew I could achieve but I also
knew that you know jogging and doing
some higher intensity aerobic exercise
would be what I need and so what I did
is I set a small little goal to be able
to
jog one mile in less than 15 minutes now
I could walk a mile in 15 minutes but I
decided just to get going so that I
could create a little mini plan for
Monday Wednesdays and Fridays to be able
to just get out there and start so it
was a realistic
goal that even though I haven't been
running for a while I knew I could
achieve it and all I had to do was get
going that was the only real decisions
is to get going jog very very slowly to
get it done now today I finished my
third day this week of doing this jog
now what I love to think about when I'm
jogging for example is as I'm getting
tired and I feel like quitting I just
pick a spot
maybe you know 100t in front of me and I
just say to myself just get there and
then once I get there I see how do I
feel I say well just get a little bit
further and I call this fractional goal
achievement I reduce it to
ridiculous um expectations ridiculously
low expectations so that I reduce the
resistance in my brain of going I don't
want to I want to quit I want to stop or
I don't want to start so when you're
setting any goal for yourself if you're
not used to setting goals or you've set
goals before and maybe you haven't
achieved them that's okay you're human
you're normal it's just part of the
process what I want you to do is set a
realistic goal for maybe just one week
from now and set up one or two or three
doable action items that you then follow
through on no matter what even if it's a
little bit you do it no matter what now
why do you want to do that well first
you want to break any patterns of
inactivity or of mental or emotional
resistance and when you just take a
little bit of action where maybe in the
past you haven't and when you push
yourself just a little bit where maybe
in the past you haven't you start to
build your neurom muscles of
self-confidence of trust of
self-respect and those three things are
required in order to achieve your goals
so realistic goal setting and realistic
goal achievement go hand in hand and
when you reduce the resistance you're
more likely to take action all right so
that's realistic goal setting a goal
achieving if you want to stretch a
little bit then what's a goal that
scares you just a little bit just a
little bit outside of your current
comfort zone and see if you could reach
that and what I always like to do is
break things down into uh one or two or
three behaviors action steps that move
you
towards that uh goal achievement move
you towards so what is it for you you
pick the goal what's one thing that I
can do that's the question you ask
yourself what's one thing I can do
that'll push me outside of my comfort
zone and what happens is just like a
rubber band when you pull a rubber band
you know when you pull it you know goes
back to its normal State and you pull it
again it goes back to its normal State
you pull it again it goes back to its
normal state after a while the band
stretches you're stretching your mind by
challenging yourself a little bit you're
stretching your emotional control by
challenging yourself a little bit and
you're challenging your
behavioral habits to stretch beyond
their comfort zone and as you stretch
your comfort zone you become more you're
capable of more and you achieve more so
reduce it to the ridiculous do it
develop that habit and I promise you you
will start achieving more and more of
your goals and dreams step number six is
set a harder goal with Jordan Peterson
with regards to your
goals let's say you don't know what to
do well maybe you're high in openness
and so you're pulled in all sorts of
directions or maybe you're low in
conscientiousness or you're confused
because you're anxious or you haven't
had any direction you haven't had good
mentoring etc etc there's lots of
reasons well I would
say pick something right pick something
a nameable goal and then try to
implement it and what'll happen is
you'll learn a lot by trying to
implement it and one of the things you
might learn is what the a a slightly
better goal might be you know because if
you try something diligently and you
succeed or you fail um you're going to
learn from the e the effort expanded in
the detailed implementation of the goal
it's going to inform you it'll also
transform you physiologically it does
that at a very basic level neuro
neurophysiological level you will be
slightly different as a consequence of
the attempt and what that'll mean is
that the next goal you pick will be a
little more suited to you and so it's
this kind of pathway right it's like
maybe the goal you should be attaining
is here but you don't know that because
you're clueless and so you aim there
well it's better than there and it's not
nothing it's not cessation of movement
and you know if you if you're supposed
to go there and you go here but you walk
diligently towards it you're a little
closer once you get to here than you
were here and it's this oscillating
self-corrective process that leads you
to the final star and you have to be
willing to engage in erroneous
experimentation to to manage that but it
is a self-correcting process and so one
of the things I always talk to my
clients about is well well let's try
something you know and and and we'll
Reserve to ourselves the right to alter
our trajectory and then I would use as a
corrective there because you might say
well how do you know when you're not
just giving out right instead of
thinking maybe you need a different goal
and I would say well you can if you're
really concerned about your proclivity
for
self-deception you can enter into a
contract with yourself that you won't
replace any goal you've set with a goal
that's
easier and so you can switch your goal
but it has to be a little harder so that
you check yourself against that tendency
to withdraw and avoid and be
self-deceptive and that works like a
charm and if you do that with some
degree of
diligence your goals will get better and
more attainable and you'll get happier
too because you don't experience
happiness except in relationship to a
goal and that's really worth knowing you
know that's another thing to think about
too if your life is meaningless while
you're not pursuing a valued goal I mean
you might be depressed too and sometimes
that can be like an illness you know
something that is really wrong with you
but A good rule of thumb is that if you
find no joy in life there's a very low
probability that you're pursuing a goal
that you regard intrinsically like in
the depths of your temperament as
worthwhile and that's technically true
because we do in fact experience most of
the positive emotion let's say that's
associated with with uh with emotions
like joy we experience that in
relationship to a goal so well then you
want to find a goal that regulates your
negative emotion and that brings you a
certain amount of positive emotion and
that expands your competence as you
pursue it and you will experence that is
Meaningful that's really what meaning
signals it meaning signals you're doing
all those things you say well that's not
real it's
like don't listen to the semantic
chatter box so
much right there's levels of you that
are far wiser than that and you can
watch what happens to you instead of
noticing what you think step number
seven is start small with David Goggins
and I started with very small goals you
know it wasn't like I went out there and
well I started out real big and I
realized that the big goals were just
crushing me you know because they
weren't happening fast enough and I had
to start making big things very small
and I had to take a lot of Pride and a
lot of uh self a lot of satisfaction
from the fact that you know I had to
lose 106 pounds in like less than three
months wow which was an impossible task
for anybody to do so instead of looking
at 106 pounds man I was happy to lose a
pound I was happy to run quarter mile CU
you know how it is as a as a powerlifter
man you're not running
anywhere not I mean for me when I was a
power lifter man I was so crazy about
calorie content and losing calories that
I hated even walk to the refrigerator
you know I didn't want to lose I didn't
lose any calories because I knew losing
calories meant losing strength so I was
I was a freak about all that stuff man
so I totally flipped my mindset about
all that stuff and just find very small
goals and start achieving them being
proud of myself through small goals that
I accomplished step number eight is set
proper goals with Alex Heros when you
set a goal usually it's like we want to
do this thing right well you're not
actually trying to do the thing you're
hoping that something's going to happen
if you do the thing we like to Define
both of those variables in the
hypothesis for example if I wanted to
have a sales goal it might say something
like if I decrease the time to call
leads from 30 minutes to 5 minutes we
will get a higher percentage of leads to
book calls that's literally the hardest
part of this whole thing is what is the
hypothesis that you're trying to test
because whenever we actually do
something in the business we're not
guaranteeing the outcome and we're not
guaranteed from the business that it's
going to create the result we want I'm
sure you've tried plenty of things that
have been goals and it didn't result in
the thing that you wanted which is why
you shouldn't state it as a goal
necessarily but as a hypothesis what you
think will happen once you have the what
problem we solving and your hypothesis
of how you're going to solve it then you
only have two variables that you have to
determine one is what's the thing I'm
going to do which is the activity that's
the input and then what do I think is
going to happen which is the output
number three what are we going to do we
are going to call leads within 5 minutes
right that is the input we check that
box great output is we will get a higher
percentage of leads to schedule or show
so You' have your Baseline of the input
which is today we're at 37 minutes and
we want to be at 5 that's the input
change the output change is going to be
we go from 50% scheduled to 70%
scheduled that's the output change that
is a goal that is what we call the
before phase the after phase only has
two columns and that's what you review
after the quarter is done or the year is
over number four what do we think's
going to happen you say okay did I do
the thing did I do the input did we
actually decrease the call time to 5
minutes if we did then that's a green
and here's where this is important we
may have decreased the call time to
under 5 minutes but we may not have
increased the scheduling at all that's
why it's a hypothesis now did what I
wanted to have happen actually happen
and then that is where you can put
commentary in so what we ended up doing
is we ended up getting it down to 7
minutes and it didn't improve it at all
at this point we don't need to get it
down to five cuz we didn't have any
directional Improvement it takes a lot
of zero to one a lot of shiny object a
lot of new things a lot of trial and
error a lot of iterate iterate iterate
until something Clicks in the beginning
but big businesses often grow by a
series of 1% improvements 1% 1% 1%
because you've seen the excel math when
you're like well if I only got 10% more
people to opt in and I got 15% more
people to uh schedule and I got 20% more
people to show and I closed one from 25%
to 35% you add all this together and all
of a sudden you triple the business and
the thing is is that every gets so
distracted with like the I'm going to
reinvent the wheel rather than just
making the wheel a little smoother so it
runs FAS and so a lot of times
especially in the 5 10 15 $20 million
Topline range that's some of the systems
we have to put in place because that's
how the big boys play they beat you
because they actually can do a 100 tiny
increments I think gym launch grew 40%
last year and we did nothing new all we
did we did everything we were currently
doing a little bit better if you do that
year after year after year you become
very hard to beat because people will
see your marketing on the outside
they'll try and copy your pages they'll
try and copy your email mails in one it
won't be you so it won't matter cuz it's
not your story but they don't know all
the internal standard operating
procedures the internal metrics that you
guys are tracking that actually create
the growth in the company and a lot of
times in the early business just
measuring metrics may be the important
goal for the quarter so that you can
then improve it let's say you're
videographer in a marketing department
right each of these goals should start
from the top down so if we say these are
our five goals as a company the
department heads are going to probably
have multiple activities to to make the
first hypothesis this is true or not I
like to have everybody as far down in
the organization do this cuz it actually
causes you to think about why you do
what you do a lot of times employees
lose motivation because they don't know
how what they do every day ties into the
bigger picture of how the company grows
and makes more money with a videographer
example they're like well what do I do
like what problem am I solving the
problem is get more customers they might
not think about it that way but that's
the goal well my hypothesis is either we
might say it's a volume thing which is
if I double the amount of shorts I make
then we will get more traffic to our
website from our organic content and at
the end of the quarter did you make
twice as many shorts okay green
fantastic did that result in more link
clicks on the site oh it didn't huh
interesting I wonder what would do it
okay we need to create more content
that's more story based great go back to
the beginning if we create more story
based content we will get more link
clicks to website that's why goal
setting if done right should take work
because it makes you think why am I even
doing what I'm doing and if you don't
take like a day for a whole quarter to
think why am I even bothering to do this
then why are you bothering to do it
without understanding what you're trying
to improve and the thing is is if you
think this way as a teammate or an
entrepreneur I promise you you will be
so much more valuable to your company if
you can even think like a business owner
and this is how a good business owner
should think and if you can approach or
whoever runs your company with this
model you may find that they will see
you differently because they're like wow
Timmy who's making these video clips is
actually thinking about what I care
about which is how I'm going to get more
customer customers whatever the second
part of the statement is if you know
what you're actually trying to
accomplish in the business then it makes
a lot easier step number nine is love
the process with Mel Robins you'll get
the day where you celebrate and that was
yesterday and you'll have that moment
where you cannot believe that you
actually got into the school that you
wanted or you got the job that you
wanted or you found the person that that
really compliments you finally or that
you got the raise that you wanted or you
built the house that you've always
dreamt of and then a funny happens after
you actually achieve the dream after you
celebrate life goes right back to the
way that it
was and for me what I'm present to is
not the fact that this talk show is
actually happening it's I'm focused on
all the work that I now need to do in
order to do the talk show as powerfully
as I can and I think that the point that
I'm trying to make about the fact that
yeah you can achieve all the things that
you're going for but I've even noticed
already in just 24 hours like that the
crazy rise in emotion and excitement has
already been replaced with things are
back to normal that is exactly what
psychologists talk about when it comes
to happiness because happiness is not
about achieving things it's not about
getting the result it's about how you
pursue the things that you enjoy and why
you're pursuing them and so the key to
life and I'm seeing it happen in my own
life is not actually checking the boxes
and getting all those things that you
dream about it's how you go about living
your life as you're pursuing them
because if I were just going to like
check the box and now I'm done biggest
goal of my life to have a daytime talk
show just to achieve that Boop what do I
have to look forward
to nothing if you've already achieved it
which is why it's so important for you
to understand that the real meaning of
happiness is about how you show up every
day yes yes you should have big goals
yes you should have Big Dreams yes yes
yes and yes you should pursue them but
don't ever think that quote making your
dreams come true is what actually makes
you happy because what actually makes
you happy is having those big dreams and
waking up every morning and doing a
little something to push yourself to
make them happen it's about the pursuit
and step number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is pursue
your truest goals with Jay Shetty the
challenge today is I'm not what I think
I am I'm not what you think I am I am
what I think you think I am now just let
that blow your mind for a moment I will
explain it I promise I'm not what I
think I am I'm not what you think I am I
am what I think you think I am which
means we live in a perception of a
perception of ourselves so I'll break it
down if I think rungan thinks I'm smart
I'll say I feel smart but if I think
rungan thinks I'm not smart then I'll
say I'm not smart and so the challenge
is that we're basing how we feel about
ourselves on what we think someone
thinks of us and and the greatest
challenge with that is how do you have
any idea if what you think someone
thinks about you is even true and
whether that's even the best place to
start so that's where our identity
struggles we start pursuing things in
life because we think other people value
them it's almost like let's think of the
most playground version of this if I
remember wearing high-tech shoes from
BHS to the playground right I remember
my mom cuz my parents didn't buy me Nik
uh trainers or Adidas trainers which I
always wanted you know we didn't come
from that background I I couldn't
couldn't afford them and my parents
didn't want me to have them so I'd walk
in with my high-tech trainers from BHS
they were about 10 quid or whatever they
were and and and you know to me me it
didn't make a difference I didn't really
know at that time whether high-tech was
good or bad they were just trainers that
my parents bought me now everyone the
cool kid at school had the latest Nik
trainers all of a sudden I start
thinking that he's now surrounded by
everyone everyone's talking about his
trainers everyone's giving him adoration
everyone's giving him respect everyone's
talking about his trainers so now I
think that if I want to have that same
experience and love from people that I
need to get that not realizing that I
may be able to get deeper love from
people by being kind and compassionate
that I may actually be able to build a
real relationship with people if I'm
loving and and considerate and
empathetic and it's so crazy how your
life can become about pursuing something
and that's why Jim Cary puts it best and
I'm paraphrasing he says you know
everyone in the world should achieve
everything they've ever wanted and
accomplish everything they've ever
pursued just to realize that it's not
the point
now that doesn't mean the monk mindset
is not about not pursuing your goals
it's actually about pursuing your truest
goals your truest self and your most
authentic aligned goals so it's not
about not having goals it's about making
sure that your gos are actually
yours as time has gone on I become less
and less a fan of goal
setting and I love the idea of quarterly
goals over annual goals over decade long
goals because the timeline is shorter
and why I'm less a fan of goal setting
is because the more you're actually
growing the less likely you're actually
able to predict where you're going to
be so I really hate 10year goals 5year
goals 10e goals if you think about where
you were 5 years ago think about who you
were 5 years ago 5 years ago like look
at the calendar 5 years ago from today
in the past who for you you think that
person could predict where you would
be 10 years
ago 10 years ago I just started my
YouTube channel I had a couple videos up
10 years ago I said I'd never want to
write a book 10 years ago I wouldn't
imagine that i' I'd be here I'd be here
and making videos for a YouTube channel
with 300 million views in Puerto Rico
because Brendan bashard invited me to
his Mastermind group to speak on stage
in front of all these successful
entrepreneurs I wouldn't have predicted
that like with with zero accuracy and
same thing for you 10 years ago you had
no idea that you'd be here not if you're
growing and this is the big caveat not
if you're growing like if you can
predict with accuracy where you're going
to be in 10
years you can hit it but it's just way
small compared to what you could have
done and it means you haven't grown in
the past
decade
and so that's my main beef against goals
and and having shorter goals having
numeric goals can be great can be great
like I want to get 10 million
subscribers on my main YouTube channel
that's a good
goal but if I set that as my 10-year
goal and that's the only thing I'm going
to do then it's wrong because probably
in 3 years I should jump off and go do
something else right I've been fortunate
that uh I've been doing YouTube for 10
years and I I still love it it's still
amazing but chance to are your 10-year
plans you should jump off in year two
and go do something else because that
thing is actually better for you because
you've grown as a
person so at least it's great the advice
that instead of annual goals set it down
the quarterly goals CU goals are still
helpful they're still good to kind of
track your progress to know that this
video did better than that video that
this customer brought in more money than
this customer that are you doing enough
action to go and get the business that
you want those are great but as a macro
thing that's leading your decisions I
think the longer you stretch it out the
worse it actually is and and it can
actually hurt you now I am definitely
the minority I think on this um I'm
actually really nervous about this
because I'm going to Brendan's second
Mastermind so Brendan bashard bot leader
awesome dude if you don't know him you
can look him up we've done some top 10
on him uh he invited me to speak at his
event in front of 200 people who paid 30
to 50K to be here and then he invited me
to stick around for him and his buddies
14 people who are all super well-known
people who you guys know uh to plan come
to his place stay with him on his Resort
for the next 3 days and plan the next
decade and I'm nervous
because I don't think that
way plan the next decade I don't I I
don't know what I'm going to say I mean
this is my practice this is what I'm
going to say and I'm not there to say
that they're wrong and I'm not here to
say Lisa's wrong either it's a different
approach it's just not how I think how I
operate how I work to plan for the next
decade as soon as I get an idea I'm
doing
it I I'm turning 40 this year in May and
people ask me what what are you going to
do for when you turn 40 like what's
going to
change I don't think that why would I
wait still months away from that
happening right like as soon as I think
about that then I have to do it right
now I'm 40 right now I'm 50 I'm 70 right
now that's how I operate as soon as you
get the idea then you go now you have a
mission and this is the thing that
aligns me right this the thing that
keeps me focused I have a mission I'm
trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I'm on a mission
forever and that mission guides me to do
bigger and bigger things I want to plan
a bigger scale I want to reach more
lives I'm never going to solve that
problem but I wake up every day trying
to go out and solve that problem so you
have a mission it's not that there's no
Clarity or no Direction the mission
gives you the direction but the further
you go out in terms of actually figuring
out the how your who and your why right
are are constant forever your who is
your most important core value belief
the why your purpose comes to your pain
is forever it's forever but the how you
go off and do it is going to
change many many many many many times
from now to when you die and so I don't
know that's how I think I'm nervous
about sharing with these guys we'll see
what they
say maybe I'll make a followup video and
give you guys an update in the future
espresso but goal setting can be really
important especially the shorter term
ones but just don't let it get in the
way of what your big term mission is
supposed to be we've all heard the says
you know how do you you know journey of
a th000 miles starts with a single step
or how do you eat an elephant one bite
at a time or you know all there all
these sayings and and it you know goes
back to the Bible and earlier right I
mean this is not new these are not new
sayings but they're showing up in
different forms what's lost in those
short descriptions however is that every
step is not equivalent if it were just
that a journey of a Thousand Miles
starts with a single step everyone would
pursue their goals everyone would push
back against adversity everyone I mean
you can read the inspirational stories
as many times as one needs and I do
think inspirational stor are of very
high value in fact I think they're
vicarious dopamine I think they give us
the sense that we could which then
orients hope which then orients us to
the world again start yeah yeah it's
maybe it's possible for me that's right
so let's say um let's take the example
of somebody who's um but just finish
that's that story of it's not about just
taking a single step and one step at a
time is it because there's adversities
every 10 steps you go and so it's harder
and harder it's not just well it's just
very nonlinear you know it's it's some
days go you know I know this from my
scientific career it's you know some
days it's easy some days it's hard it's
all over the place right so I think the
thing to remember is that dopamine is
this incredibly powerful molecule that
allows us to buffer the effort process
it allows us to be in effort longer and
allows us to actually eventually enjoy
the process of effort and not think
about the reward but just say oh I'm
enjoying the process right well you just
described the first step the first step
in learning to attach dopamine to the
effort process which is the key
operation in order to succeed is to be
very careful about how much you focus on
the end goal keeping the goal in mind is
important for like a proper orientation
you have to know the ultimate
destination but if at any point we were
to evaluate our progress relative to
that end goal or if we don't know what
the end goal is there's a huge gap there
and it can feel overwhelming and
depressing and I'm not good enough I
should just give up what am I doing this
for those thoughts will affect us and
they're very realistic right I mean as
Carol will say and other people said in
the psychology field you know positive
selft talk often times unless you do it
correctly you're badly wrong you know
lying to yourself won't work saying
saying I'm I'm a winner I'm a winner I'm
a winner when you haven't or you haven't
won yet is is great but that's not the
most effective use of these systems well
you're also being out of Integrity with
yourself you're you're telling yourself
a lie right you're Li
and then you're losing your ability to
have confidence because you're just
lying to yourself right and if it's
really extreme there's a name for it
it's called delusional right right and
people will start to point that out and
then it becomes harder to recruit people
into your your goals so I think the key
thing is to attach that sense of reward
to the effort process it's saying look I
am oriented in the right direction and
rewarding the things you're not doing
I'm not back on my heels I'm not just
staying you know in bed in morning yeah
a good example this came to me recently
I have a good friend he did nine years
in the SEAL Teams his name is Pat dosset
and and we were talking about you know
the Admiral M Craven thing you know get
up and make your bed and you know and
they they really do that and I think the
way it was described was um you know so
at the end of the day even if everything
doesn't go well your bed is still made
for me that's not that big of a reward
frankly right but I and so I said that
and I I love it though I make my bed oh
I definitely make my bed in the morning
but I mean going back and seeing that at
the end of a hard day mhm it it's not
enough I felt like there was something
else there so I asked him he said well
it's very interesting because part of it
is about not just making your bed but
it's the things you're not doing by
making your bed you're not lying in bed
and ruminating you're not back on your
heels on your phone that's right when so
when you look at and you have spent a
lot of time with people in high
performing communities mainly through
some Consulting work but what you find
is that you know we can all be either be
back on our heels flat footed or forward
Center MK and when you look at people
who are in these high performance
communities they try and keep their
Center of mass forward almost through
what seem like trivial things like
making your bed or making the cup of
coffee but it's not just about what
you're doing it's all the things you're
not doing that can put you down the path
of ruminating or put you down the path
of um unhealthy Behavior so the key to
this is if we want to be very concrete
we should probably focus on actions and
I'll use Fitness as an example because
it translates to everybody whereas you
know people's circumstances differ let's
say somebody really wants to take on a
fitness routine they hate running or
they want to lose weight in a in a
healthy way this kind of thing so we've
all heard the example well you put your
shoes by the door on day one day two you
put them on day three you go out the
door day four you walk around the block
and then you know and then eventually
like they're running marathons okay
great but to sustain that behavior or
even to make the the behavior
pleasureful and to give you energy the
key is to subjectively reward those
steps so it's not going let's say I go
and I run a mile and my goal is to run
10 miles in a few weeks the key is as
you're in the strain of that mile the
hard part you want to tell yourself this
is the good part this is the part that
gives me energy and I'll be very
surprised if people don't actually feel
like they could continue further so it's
a journey of a Thousand Miles starts
with the single is made up of you know
single steps but the key is to reward
the harder steps not the easier ones and
not the ones where you get the thing
that you want don't reward yourself for
putting your shoes on and taking a step
outside you could if that was a huge
barrier for you it's very hard if it was
very hard for you running the 10 miles
is hard find the wall and push a little
bit further through that wall and reward
that process so this is why I think reps
in the gym the the final reps like reps
to failure are usually not the best
example first of all most people aren't
doing reps to failure and it doesn't
translate to young kids and stuff where
they probably shouldn't be doing heavy
this kind of thing what you want however
is if you're going to go there to think
about these are the this is the hard
part CU that's when adrenaline nor up
and Effron are getting maxed out and
that's when you have an opportunity to
bring dopamine in and teach those neural
Pathways to slam that back down and I
don't want to um highlight them too much
because they are a very Niche and
specialized Community but you look at
people in Special Operations you look at
the um process like the whole um
evaluation process of who gets in and
who doesn't it's really about putting
people into stress and seeing who can
not just make it through that stress but
buffer that stress reward the process
through teamwork reward the process of
stress through some internal dialogue
that has everything to do with not being
back on your heels not being flat footed
but Center of mass forward and I should
also be clear I'm not talking about
everybody being super aggro and always
like you know work work work yeah in
fact if you're spending too much
epinephrine if you're too much of an
adrenaline junkie you will burn out
eventually unless you can find ways to
recover yourself or to buffer that with
dopamine and the recovery process is
especially important there's a second
reward system so you've got the dopamine
system and I guess to really put a box
around it the subjective reward needs to
be done at the hardest portion of a
process the tough conversation with a
significant other it's like when it's
really tough and you want you just
that's when you want to start telling
yourself this is the this is the good
part because I'm not speaking or this is
the good part because I'm not reacting
right I'm not reacting or this is the
good part because I'm probably not doing
it correctly but I'm on the right path
right um they're upset they're not
feeling your empathy you know this kind
of thing or you're not really
understanding what's going on you're
getting frustrated but if you tell
yourself this is this is the neural
pathway getting ground in there like
really dialed in so that the the next
time this I'm going to Breeze right past
this that's really how the process works
works because dop remember no one comes
along and drips dopamine in your ear
even if you get a billion dollars or you
win a Nobel Prize or you win the
presidency it's all internal these
neurochemicals are all internal and
while some of them are designed to be
released in response to things very
reflexively like um you know food sex
sleep you know all these things will
trigger these neurochemicals we have
this big forbrain which allows us to
place subjective context on things
Common Sense isn't always common
practice and this is why we have to go
back to the fundamentals sometimes
before we can get to those Advanced
tactics before we can get more subtle
and into more nuanced things so the
habit is this write down your goals
studies show in fact a study by Dr um uh
Halverson showed that we human beings
are literally 42% more likely to achieve
our goals if we simply write them down
and this isn't about magic well there is
some magic to it but in a very literal
sense it's about Focus you know Vision
one of the things that I did I had this
dream when I was writing the book which
by the way I was horrible at writing
this book I was so stressed out I was
putting so much pressure on myself I
wanted so badly to make it as good as it
could possibly be and I was driving
myself Bonkers and one of the things I
did every morning I didn't just write
down my goals for the book I had a very
specific goal which was this I wanted to
the best of my ability to set up this
book to be a number one New York Times
bestseller and you and I both know
because we have so many friends in the
industry and so many authors you can't
control that you know especially if
you're doing it completely organically
right it's one of those things you just
kind of hope for maybe it'll happen
maybe it won't but here's what I did
Vision I took that idea that simple
habit of just writing down goals and I
went further I wrote down I am a number
one New York Times bestseller 15 times
every single morning in my journal for
probably about 18 months I still have
have all the journals in my drawers uh
in my house 15 times every single
morning that is so interesting every
morning and it was using the words I am
right so it was just I am a number one
New York Times bestselling author I am a
number one New York Times bestselling
author and my intention was around this
book again completely consciously
knowing first of all that that is an
arbitrary goal second of all there's a
little bit of ego involved but third of
all I also knew that if I could at least
get on list or maybe get to be number
one the most important thing for me
wasn't about the title for myself it was
about the fact that that would get this
book and this message into more hands it
would give it that extra little bit of
credibility that would hopefully get
this idea out and one of the things um I
wrote about in the beginning of the book
was this you know a friend of mine who
is the CEO of Shopify I ran into him in
New York while I was working on the book
and by working on the book I mean
stressing out over it and Toby uh is his
name he's like you know what are you
working on I said I'm working on this
book and he's like why are you writing a
book he's like like that's a huge
project your business is going great you
have so many other things going on like
why did you say yes to this and I said
Toby you know what if I were to get hit
by a bus tomorrow and I could only leave
one thing behind it would be this idea
if I can do a good enough job explaining
this philosophy this belief and the
profound transformation that it can
spark in every human being then I can be
like riding off on the Unicorn my Cosmic
next adventure going like all right I
did it peace
taking it back to 2010 but that was the
feeling I had so um you know this idea
of writing that down every single
morning and it was like 5:00 a.m. you
know and sometimes I would be so blurry
eyed and I didn't want to do it but I
did it every single morning 15 times and
when the uh New York Times list came out
the week after we published Vision I
like broke down in the ugly cry like I
could not even breathe I was partially
exhausted cuz we were on tour and I was
traveling around and doing just you know
like a ton of stops or whatever and
partially just so um humbled and so
emotionally just like an emotional
release uh so that's the Habit The Habit
it's so simple write down your goals if
you want to supercharge it if you want
to take it to that next level and you
have a singular goal that you're working
on right now that is more important to
your heart than anything else write it
down 15 times a day we all know we have
something called the reticular
activating system that part of our brain
that helps us sit in sort what's
important and what's not and on the most
basic level writing your top goal down
every single day 15 times will give you
the focus that you need every morning to
not get distracted by shiny objects and
to do everything in your power to
activate that goal and to help bring it
to life we can replace any limiting
story with a story of empowerment and
when you attach those emotions to goals
oh you become Unstoppable Where You Are
maybe okay but it's not who you're meant
to be so you know where you are with
honesty then we must decide where is it
that we truly want to go who do we want
to be in a year from now think of that
question I didn't say what do you want
who do you want to become a year from
now what kind of income Happiness joy
Health do you want let's pretend it's a
year from now pretend it's the yes best
year of our lives and what does that
look like when you look in the mirror
when you look in your bank account when
you get up to do your daily thing is it
going to an office or is it doing your
own thing where you're impacting others
right why do you want to make more money
have more love have a better body or be
in better shape why do you want to find
selflove again or get out of that bad
habit why it's always deeper right could
be for family could be for Freedom could
be because you want control of your
decisions your time right could be that
you want to be a better parent a better
husband a better wife a better spouse a
better significant other I don't know
your why but when you attach your heart
to your
goal you be become Unstoppable the last
piece if you know where you are and you
know where you want to go if you attach
your heart the last piece is how are you
going to get there what capabilities do
you need to keep your mindset sharp to
never lose your confidence to stay in
the right State of Mind to unleash that
inner hero that lives in all of us to
stay happy abundant to focus on
solutions to move forward to not feel
like an impostor what capabilities do
you need when you want to learn
something find somebody who's living the
life you want that truly has the depth
and breath and is willing and has
willing to create a course a workshop a
mastermind gain the capabilities and
make it happen I've been in the
self-education industry for over 24
years and I want to give you the common
denominator of the people that break
through and have the greatest year of
their life and shift like fundamentally
shift their future forever you see they
do gain the capabilities the how from
someone who's already been there but you
have to be careful once you get the
knowledge that's not enough that must be
combined with the addiction please write
this down right now with the addiction
of
uncomfortable
action we must get addicted to
uncomfortable action we must get
addicted to courageously moving forward
courage isn't moving forward in the
absence of fear courage is moving
forward even if you're a little scared
even if you've never done it before even
if you feel like an impostor even if you
feel like your friends will think you're
crazy or your family members or your
spouse that is what we must get addicted
to so the magical combination for
success is gaining capabilities from
someone who's already been there someone
who's crafted the blueprint and then
shifting your mindset to say I'm going
to go for this and if I fail
congratulations that means I'm pushing
myself because if you haven't failed
much that means you're playing safe and
you don't like safe or you wouldn't be
here right now and that's the part I
missed yesterday I thought it was so
important for you to understand if you
feel uneasy about moving forward
congratulations if you feel a little
nervous have butterflies about starting
the business scaling the business doing
the sales doing the marketing having
that conversation with your husband
talking to your children walking into
the gym if it's making you a little
nervous congratulations your next level
of Life lives on the other side of that
uncomfortable action but again you want
the
blueprint and the action and then it's
game over the ability to assess
accurately whether or not you're
actually moving towards your goals so
everything starts with this hyp specific
goal and this is why you can't in any
way shape or form be nebulous about what
it is you want to do and I think that a
lot of people are super vague about what
their goals are and the easiest way for
me to explain it is to say most people
have the equivalent of a goal in their
mind of something like this what the
words they actually use this is the
single most common I want to help people
okay great that's really Noble and I
love that and I love that that's
something that I hear all the time but
the problem is that's like saying I want
to win uh a gold medal in the Olympics
okay well summer or winter summer great
uh tennis or swimming swimming great
which event because until you get to the
exact event that you want you don't know
what to train you don't know what skills
you need you don't know what muscle
groups you need to be training you don't
have the goal in mind and if you can't
measure it you can't improve it so you
need to create some environment where
you know here are the things that I'm
going to measure that I need to get good
at in order to win that gold medal so if
you want to win the gold medal then you
need to understand what kind of time do
you have to swim in that event in order
to qualify historically for a gold medal
that's a really good place to start and
then looking at the Contemporary
competition and understanding on their
best day where they're setting the bar
for a gold medal and either you're
swimming that fast or you're not and so
it all becomes entirely measurable you
can find trainers and coaches that
understand how to get you there but it
all started with that really really
specific goal so if you don't have that
specific goal then you can't even put a
road map by which then you can see if
you're actually making progress towards
that or not so invariably in the
beginning you're almost certainly going
to be doing the wrong things you're
going to be doing things that aren't
moving you as rapidly towards your goal
as you want but when you can measure it
and you have that road map and you can
accurately identify whether or not
you're taking steps then you can adjust
tweak and move on so I'll give you guys
an example the whole reason that I'm
here in New York was to meet with the
former head of one of the major Comic
Book companies and literally I said I
have two questions and I spent two days
with them over the next two days your
job is to help me answer two questions
question number one why am I going to
fail and then question number two once I
understand why I'm going to fail how do
I ensure that I
succeed and then you really look at just
the really hard answers and once you
have that in place then it's like okay
I've got a rough idea of what I need to
be executing against the things that I'm
going to need to learn the people that
I'm going to need to talk to the
problems with distribution that have to
be solved or accounted for all of that
and then you go build out answers to
those problems you see which ones work
and then you change and adjust as you go
but that really is um at a very high
level one of the things you have to do
talk to people that already know get
them to break down for you the things
you need to be doing and that's how you
evolve your thinking over time all right
next question is from Carolina Wilk this
is from Facebook Tom exclamation point
how do you make yourself do things that
you don't want to but have to
to there's really only one way that I
know to do this reliably and that is to
really care deeply about the thing that
you're trying to do so to me it's it's
about identifying something that you get
more energy out of than it takes from
you and I think people try to sum that
up by saying find something that you're
passionate about and first of all you
have to be really careful because you
don't find you're going to create
passion passion is created it's not
discovered so how do you learn to create
that excitement around something that
you care about so do that by
encountering a lot of things until you
find one that really peques your
interest and then engage with that
heavily and as you engage with that
learn to Fan the Flames to really create
it as an obsession which one of the
easiest ways to create it as an
obsession goes like this say in your
head this is something that I really
enjoy I love it interests me for all
these reasons like loop back over that
as to why it's something that really
drives you focus on the things that you
like repeat it in your head man I really
got into that I got into it for this
reason this is why I'm excited about
this and then externalize that and a
huge part of this and one of the things
that I do one of the reasons that when
I'm doing a live like this like these
guys will tell you in the room 2 seconds
before we started rolling I was talking
in a totally different manner than I am
right now I'm using much bigger um
physical expressions and I do that
because I for these lives to give me
more energy than they take I need to
embody the excitement I need to remind
myself of connecting with you guys and
why that's important to me and why
that's fun and in doing that it makes me
want to do the next live even more
because I remember how it gave me energy
instead of just taking it away and I
think about connecting with you guys and
I think about the people that write in
and all that stuff so I'm intentionally
doing that I'm intentionally Al looping
looping around the things in the
community that bring value to me I'm
intentionally embodying my excitement
during this so that then as I replay
this later in my mind that I remember
how it was exciting and it was fun so
learning to do those things learning to
take conscious control of that process
is going to give you the excitement that
you need then when you hit those things
that you don't want to be doing you're
so excited and you so embody that
enthusiasm for the thing you're trying
to do that you believe in that mission
that goal that thing that like you would
you would die for and you've built into
your life to live for it that thing is
giving you that energy it it becomes
your passion and that passion is the
thing that's going to see you through
but you created all of that so make sure
that whatever you're trying to do you
actually give a about that's the
real
answer
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how wealthy people achieve their goals
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I mean mostly
subscribe to Scientific periodicals the
The Daily News I find to be a lot of
noise um and just very negative seem to
be trying to ask the question what is
the worst thing that happen on Earth
today something terrible happened every
single day